[Musique]
ce jeudi 12 mai c'est sur le départ du
chemin des anglais réduits lazaret de la
grande chaloupe que les départements a
dévoilé le programme de la 16e édition
de la fête de la nature qui se tiendra
du 18 au 22 mai prochain les réunionnais
auront rendez vous avec les plus beaux
sites naturels et les paysages
remarquables de lille pendant cinq jours
avec des manifestations gratuites et
accessibles à tout public nous allons
démarrer la 16e édition des fêtes de la
nature et bien je vous invite j invite
les réunionnaises et les réunionnais à
redécouvrir la nature réunionnaise à la
protéger bien évidemment à la valoriser
et à faire en sorte que les enfants
d'aujourd'hui puissent être sensibilisés
à tout ce qui touche à nos forêts darin
à travers cette sixième édition de la
fête de la nature nous favorisons aussi
l'accessibilité pour les personnes
porteuses d'un handicap c'est un enjeu
majeur parce que la forêt les et les
espaces naturels sont la propriété de
tout un chacun de tout le monde y
compris bien évidemment des presses des
personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap l'occasion également pour le
département de célébrer avec ses
partenaires et avec la presse les 30 ans
de sa politique de préservation et de
valorisation des espaces naturels
sensibles et de la biodiversité
aujourd'hui nous lançons la célébration
des 30 ans de la politique des espaces
naturels sensibles du département et
c'était important de marquer le coup
cette année en mettant en avant cette
démarche on a vraiment le souhait de
mettre en lumière tous nos partenaires
et tous nos gestionnaires de sites de
mettre en lumière leurs actions qui sont
nombreuses depuis de nombreuses amies
sur le sur les sites départementaux pour
les fêtes de la nature donc
les 130 manifestations à peu près 25
sites à découvrir ou à redécouvrir avec
deux nouveaux sites donc 1 à la forêt de
bébour et un autre à
la forêt de mare longue à saint-philippe
et il y aura également les retours des
nuitées tant attendu par la population
donc les nuitées ça sera sur le site du
camp marron au dimitile à l'antre-2 et
sur le site de python mon verre comme
chaque année l'objectif de la fête de la
nature est de sensibiliser le public à
la protection du patrimoine naturel de
l'île tout en découvrant ou redécouvrant
ses richesses sur la fête de la nature
ne va intervenir non sur six sites
notamment la forêt des oignons verts la
forêt de sans souci d'un poids total la
forêt de notre dame de la paix et à deux
marchands d'eau et donc il y aura des
animateurs que la prendre en charge des
groupes de deux publics pour en fait
apprécier la diversité des milieux
naturels à la réunion et donc en
fonction de ces milieux là il va voir la
richesse qui se dégage en termes de
diversité à la fois sur la foi ni loi
sur la plan et sur les habitats naturels
il ya aussi bien bien sûr les espèces
endémiques et indigènes que les
emblématiques à vos agendas la fête de
la nature c'est du mercredi 18 au
dimanche 22 mai pour découvrir tout le
programme de cette 16e édition et les
nombreuses activités proposées aux
quatre coins de l'île rendez vous sur le
site du département de la réunion
[Musique]